this is odessa's resistance force
they're made up of ordinary men and
women preparing to defend themselves
they're making camouflage netting from
scraps of fabric but that's not all
they're making
so through here
we're told that they're
making the molotov cocktails and we've
seen a lot of this in ukraine volunteers
bottles making effectively hand thrown
bombs for if the invasion comes to their
town
if russian forces make it here the
people of odessa want to do all they can
to fight back okay this is it
bogdan is just 22 years old a history
student now making history himself
i see okay yeah there's a strong smell
of petrol coming from the lockup and
it's clear that bogdan's been busy
one two three four five six seven eight
nine 10 11. i think 14
crates
of molotov cocktails
full of fuel
capped with foil and they'll throw it at
whoever they want to throw it at and
it'll blow up
sort of the ultimate
civil defense
and they're making these all over
ukraine
no question
every day we make more than a thousand
bottles if the enemy comes into the city
we will make much more than that
thousands of men have already signed up
to fight
going from civilian to soldier in just a
few weeks
we're on our way to a military base
which is in the center of odessa and
it's being manned by
soldiers from territorial defense many
of them have only just signed up in the
last few weeks from ordinary jobs
and we can't identify the location for
obvious reasons
[Applause]
they they let us have this floor
uh pretty much sleep on the floor with
whatever volunteers bring to us
so far we even have bananas and horn
just everything
but i'm afraid it's gonna not gonna last
for long
vladimir nagorni was a film producer
before the war now he's second in
command of this army unit
so this is our kitchen where guys eat
like uh riding lunges here
as the guys
it's dark and cramped in here
the men eat where they can
and they sleep where they can
we're ready to die and we're not afraid
i'm not afraid to give pay this high
price
not to achieve something but stop this
country from something and this would be
becoming part of this terrible russia
russian state i feel like i'm in a movie
they're bracing themselves for war here
now
for the dark days that might lie ahead
nick martin sky news odessa